okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolf language design review part of our
language completeness and consistency
series
and looks like we have seemingly two
straightforward topics except that I
know neither of them are straightforward
let's start off with this
optional plus longest shortest
right so
there was a user complaint about the
interaction of optional with longest and
shortest and sort of
digging in to this you know I think
they're sort of two
uh two main behaviors at play here the
first is when you have shortest around
an optional it always prefers to use
uh the default
um
which uh
um you know is
you know a little questionable but uh
you know see right seems to be
um
okay hold on
what is the basic Point here is this an
interaction between longest shortest and
options pattern
an options pattern or is it you're
talking about optional I'm talking about
optional okay so if you if if you and
now the particular case that the users
uh user was interested involved both
optional and options pattern but
um but before we dig into his example I
think we should uh you know understand
has nothing to do with it it's optional
and shortest and longest
right
so if you if you open up the shortest
example you'll see sort of
uh I sent you is this the example I sent
that that is the exactly the example you
sent me and and I used replace list
rather than just a function definition
just so we can see that yeah you know
right just so we see that right there
are multiple matches pattern you know
multiple matches possible and you know
sort of the question is when you're
writing a function definition obviously
the first one is used
um
so if you
um right so here you know you have a
function with an optional right that's X
is null blank sequence with a default
value of true and if you you know call f
on it then the preferred match is
binding x to the empty sequence because
no blank sequence will match the empty
sequence and then binding X to True
um
now if you wrap that pattern let me just
understand that particular game mode
Okay so
to match F of no arguments
the preferred possibility
I don't understand I don't understand
when when it uses optional it is first
using the pattern and then deciding to
filter deciding not the pattern and in
here the pattern happens to match
nothing so that that's what matches I
don't know if that's helpful but that's
that is but the point is that optional
is post filling once
the thing has matched the pattern
then it's like
yeah no I'm sorry no no I'm wrong I'm
wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong
in this case the pattern matches nothing
but also the case where it ignored the
pattern completely and just went to the
optional is that second case correct
that's correct
okay
right now if you wrap that optional and
shortest or or if you involve shortest
in the pattern with optional then it
decides to completely ignore the pattern
and just go straight to default value it
reverses it reverses the choice yes
why
um because shortest of optional will try
matching the case where there's nothing
there first
all right I didn't write this but I
don't think this is crazy right I don't
think it's crazy it's possibly arguable
but it's hold on isn't it if if we
switch this wouldn't longest either be
inconsistent or have a different problem
the equivalent problem
uh the basic point is shortest is
preferring
the match where
it is the very shortest thing which is
the which is the non thing as in the
thing which eventually goes to the
optional correct correct yes that's
that's a true statement
um okay
and then longest
uh can we not do this exact same example
um
we could
I think longest would have basically no
effect right because right that's what I
would expect
yep
okay
so shortest knows that a non-thing is
shorter than anything else
right exception
that's not literally true right right
that's okay it happens to be the same
length as the actual match right
a case probably not imagined when this
code was written
okay
right well I don't have a big objection
to what shortest is doing in this case
no I I don't I think we should put this
as notes or something in shortest yes we
should
yeah
um right
so the the well I guess we can look at
this example first so if you wrap in
um
right so basically if you wrap the if
the sorry if the optional comes first
so right I have two arguments here yep
if they're optional thing comes first
then longest has no effect I guess
basically because right things to the
specifications to the left have higher
priority than specifications to the
right
um
if the optional thing comes later then
it has an effect
so you see the first two are the same
but the second two it has changed the
order of the uh of the first two matches
um
because so go ahead you're right because
in the first two examples it's the x
that has the default value and in the uh
last example it's y that has the default
value
so when you try to wrap and notice in
particular here I'm wrapping the thing
that's not optional and longest so I
would expect in that last case that it's
going to make that Y is going to be
bound to the non thing
that's not what happens
well because y matches the empty
sequence right so the the false gets
eaten up by
the
X because X is now longest and then Y is
perfect Y is not wrapped in longest or
shortest so it's perfectly happy to just
bind the empty sequence to y
hm hmm
and I
I will do nothing right but if you
wrapped it in shortest
then it'll give you
that
which is kind of weird but consistent
with the discussion we've had up till
now
yes I see the shortest so the main thing
to note
is that
or shortest the non-thing is shorter
than any things
that makes sense yeah shortest will
prefer a non-thing to anything even if
that thing
is an effect an empty sequence
right I think that's explainable yep
yeah it's specific to shortest and
optional
yeah but I think it's consistent and the
coach carefully implements this so
somebody thought okay well I think
there's nothing further to discuss here
I think we should consider this fine but
requiring that additional clarification
in the documentation
right I just wanna I mean the one thing
that that that's you know worth pointing
out but I think uh you know I don't
think we're going to change this but if
if you look right so the user was
specifically interested in the case
where you know he has an optional
argument and then options pattern and he
tried to make it longer
by wrapping it in longest then it had no
effect
um and um
and I well I guess I uh that's I guess
you know that's exclusive the same
phenomenon or something different
that is the same phenomenon right
because the
uh oh actually the options pattern
prefers
no I'm confused if it was wrapped in
shortest I understand the option pattern
prefers going to the optional case
rather than having any content
right so options well this options
pattern is like null blank sequence
effectively in this particular case
right it it matches zero or more options
specifications so you know but you know
a rule matches blank also so when you
just do x blank
uh comma true sorry colon true then that
still matches x blank now you can wrap
the first argument and shortest to get
sort of
the you know Force optional things into
Ops
um you know
I wouldn't have expected that longest
oh I see
longest
you might have thought would crush the X
down to being it's
optional case correct right
exactly that was the user's expectation
okay so explain to me why that's okay
but it doesn't do that
right because
um
the
um we're just left to right Max matching
isn't that the reason yeah basically
because it was the other way around I
think it would do it yep
well I guess we I guess we can test that
but I'm pretty sure based on all the
examples we've looked at thus far that
would be my expectation as well
it isn't doing it is it
um
well right he I get I guess the point is
that
um
okay so I guess this is a little uh
thank you
so maybe there's also an issue with
longest and shortest and options pattern
although I I claim that the very first
example where we had a longest of
obstacle and options pattern if Ops was
no blank sequence we would have the
exact same behavior
um
a little confused by that second case
there
comparing which input are you referring
to in 40. and this one here it could
yeah well I think that option I mean
whether this made options pattern as
long as possible right so yeah the
options pattern is matching
something is grabbing something first
and then the sequence is oh oh no no oh
no no no no
we didn't reverse the things we're
looking at us backwards right so x x
right X is grabbing
uh yeah X is still grabbing the role in
all these cases I know which is
surprising to me yeah in this case here
I would have expected that the longest
of options pattern would grab the whole
rule
longest is not modifying the optional
yeah so that is possibly no the option
not the optional the options pattern
so the longest
of the sequence options pattern I think
here is just the sequence
um
that is not modifying the optional
the optional is matching first
yes right
I think this is arguably wrong
I think the other Behavior we've seen is
not wrong but I think the interaction
was longest and shortest with options
better needs to be looked at
right yeah I guess the thing is that
options pattern almost always goes at
the end right and well I would think you
could put a sequence in there if if you
want to and yeah it can can we copy that
in a 14 and change options patterns and
null blank sequence
or give it a name
yeah
delete that
yeah I mean do troubling
what is this what are you talking about
dude travel long to score yeah that's
what I would have thought
so it's the same
hold on
yeah which is arguably wrong
I don't understand this
so maybe
maybe well then right so maybe the
statement that
well I guess it's the statement that
when you have an OP an optional it which
is not explicitly wrapped in uh uh
shortest then it prefers the non
uh yeah I think that's what's Happening
Here plus the unwrapped thing
correct I don't think this is right
I can see no argument for n23 being
right
well the I'll tell you what the argument
is I'm not saying whether this is
correct
in this case the optional is is working
first I know
I don't think it's right
right but then what's the argument for
having a different behavior when it
appears in the first slot
what are you saying what
so because the copy that down and
reverse right or or
the first case we had here right
I think that one's arguably wrong as
well
I mean I could argue for that in terms
of a left right thing but I think it's
not really that convincing
I think there's a case that we just
haven't considered very carefully is is
the crushing
of length
based on something being an optional
I think this deserves more investigation
I don't think it's the most important
thing but I think I don't think this is
right
um
so I guess the question is why were you
okay with the argument that you know
things that are not wrapped in optional
prefer the thing first
because because that was a one argument
case
optional
right so like with uh
you know when we just looked at the
shortest example in in the in the exam
in the section titled shortest example
right so
um
in this case it preferred to bind F to
null blank sequence but then when we
explicitly wrapped it in shortest it
preferred the default value
yes but this is a different case because
in one case we have competition between
a shortest or longest and nothing
and the other case we have
the decision within a single object
which would it prefer
I think they're different
I think this requires more investigation
I think I think it's possibly not quite
right
okay let
me point out that if if if if you if you
if you took optional out of the equation
so that was X null blank sequence and
you know Ops no bling sequence I believe
you'd get the same behavior
which one
so take uh
uh the
uh the very first input there
and
make it x triple underscore and Ops
triple underscore
just here x yep
and
uh I mean this isn't defined what it did
is a little weird but it certainly isn't
defined I thought we said we match the
shortest Thing by default which is
what's happening here so X matches the
shortest thing like nothing and then
whatever's left over has to go towards
put
shortest around Ops
right
um
yeah that seems right
right if you put longest there right it
would not make any difference no you'd
have to put longest around the first
thing
right let's just check because oops
longest
okay
but if we put longest round the first
thing then it will force
I'm just for the hell do I just want to
see if it does for them but okay fine
okay
that's fine those are fine that sounds
fine right and I think I think if we did
options pattern
instead of null blank sequence we would
get the same behavior
it's yeah it's right it's when you stick
in the optional that
we get this discrepancy I guess because
it prefers to try to when it's not
explicitly wrapped it prefers to try the
you know the the something as opposed to
nothing
all right I think we've got some stuff
to look at with options pattern but
other than that this looks okay okay
let's move on this is an important topic
here
right so last time uh we started time
was a while ago right right and it was
you're like oh we need to
you know we need we need Chris you know
we need people and we need to spend the
whole meeting on this so it's this is a
little less than a whole meeting but uh
all right I've just sort of collected
you know things from our previous
discussions but I you know you clearly
want to take this in some Direction so
I'm going to let you oh no I mean the
main thing is
there's code and you want to manipulate
it that's the main thing so you've got a
piece of code and you you're trying to
tweak the code in some way without it
blowing up in your face
foreign
expression so I could say held of
immediate evaluate
um
now
it's something that you could put into
um
uh
like uh a rule
um yeah into a pattern so when it's
substitute when you substitute it in
um
right so you know do hold of two
and uh no no no no no well
yeah this is the one that would become
hold of four
uh well I mean I I suppose it depends on
what conventions we would come up with
for uh
you know what what what attributes
immediate evaluate would would have
right I mean if if you just uh or or is
that oh that's a rule delayed which I
can't quite is that a rule delayed that
I can't quite see at this resolution can
I do I need to make it bigger
okay now I can clearly see that it's a
rule delayed
um
okay yes
um I mean I think right that of course
that's that's a really boring case
because you already have in the thing
right of all the information the more
interesting case is hold of two slash
dot X goes to
uh you know x blank goes to immediate
immediate evaluate of x blank squared
yes
right so
um you know which I mean this particular
you know
right of course you can do that with you
know with and slash semi but uh
right
well but with Slash tell me you have to
test the match explicitly you can just
use the bottom matcher
uh you can use the slash semi with the
pattern matcher I mean I right I mean
it's kind of cumbersome right but right
you can achieve the same effect right
yeah obviously you can right but this
seems useful unless it's semantically
clear
um
[Music]
I'm sorry
we did green light them previously
no I understand
so this applies
this does evaluation upon
substitution basically right yep
which is not quite what you'd expect
immediately evaluate to do
right and and right I think this was
going to be sort of more I it's been
long enough that I don't remember all
the details but right I think this was
going to be sort of much more General
than just right pattern matching right
if you wanted to use it with say map
um right because right so you could get
it into you could insert it into a place
where it would not normally be
evaluated
um I mean the problem is if we had
something like hold
of X Plus
well
you can just hold of X
um
right I mean right if we have hold of
two and we map hash squared over that
um look here if we say immediate
evaluate
to help
okay just to see what will happen here
right that's this case remove the braces
around uh oh I guess you're going to
rely on the Lost ability okay fine
I think the Ampersand should be inside
the immediate evaluate yeah
that that was going to be the
right the convention
I'm totally confused so this is
right so so remove in in the previous
input remove the immediate evaluate so
we we know we're looking at the present
Behavior
Al behavior is not useful because it's
just going over those things well maybe
it's not useful for you I critically
rely on this behavior all the time
okay
right so that's the thing which we would
like to have some way to get it not to
do that
correct
and so if we wrap the first argument and
immediate evaluate that would tell
uh the substitution system well the the
well it will tell map to run ieval on
you know
right when it copies the experts rather
than just copying and and sticking at
the head
to I eval each expression
um so that the result is evaluated yes
right but how General is that phenomenon
of you have you've got a function and it
stuffs
a completely value in
and that new value but it is into an
environment
where
you know where it's been uh where it's
being held
I would say that's pretty General I mean
everything in the map family
um
you know everything in the replace
family I mean it's explicitly listed in
the notes that right the first
sticks things in and then allows
normally I know okay there's there are
there any other kinds of functions other
than the map and replace family that do
that
um structural functions of this kind
that go into something else I mean I
don't know something like grouping does
it do anything like this I don't think
so I think most of the functions they
create a thing for themselves the main
point here is that they are inserting
into something well replace part
certainly does this
right which I would say I mean that's
somewhere between map and replace but
it's generically within the map and
replace family
right
so the whole point is that the semantics
here would be immediate evaluate
causes it upon insertion
to do it so it's evaluate upon insertion
correct
it seems like a very useful thing to me
I mean I sit and use it now is there any
kind of quoting the unquoted quoting you
know there's any kind of weird
it just doesn't evaluate it evaluates
only when it gets the signal I've just
been substituted right so I think the
well I mean I don't know how this would
work you know I haven't thought through
if they're sort of multiple levels of
quoting that we might want to worry
about but generically speaking
[Music]
um
the uh
I I think the question is really this if
you do this and then you do it again
it's already blown itself up right the
first time you do it it's going to
evaluate so if the thing inside it
if it contains another immediate
evaluate that's fine that will that will
just be left as an immediate evaluate
the immediate evaluate its only
operation is
to do
don't we have some kind of uh release at
type functionality
uh
uh I mean if I said here map at release
hold
in that
comma
one two
nope
but out of luck it can't do anything do
we have any such functionality
no uh
um
I mean the closest thing you could do is
right you could do replace at and uh you
know use a rule that basically forces it
to evaluate all right but I mean that
would also be potentially useful as to
have a release hold which has a part
number in it that would be more useful I
think
this in whatever we call it well except
well I mean well I don't think it I
don't think a release hold with a part
number and it works because unless
you're saying oh you're saying you you
would apply it from the outside yes okay
you're right because I was going to say
release hold can only work from the
outside it's like evaluate at
it's like map app but it's evaluate
yes
but this immediate value whatever
slightly problematic I mean what about
in with or or Lambda evaluation or
something
well that's the question does that
counter substitution it's like a huge
set well no no no
what cancer substitution that's the big
question everything everything no no
wait wait a second so we first said
that it is the you know map family the
replace family
Okay now what's being raised is could it
also be the function family
yeah with
okay let's look at with
I don't understand why with is relevant
here I mean with literally
x equals immediate evaluate of the
function and then X bracket you know
five or something
inside a hold right so then right hold
of you know X yeah yeah right
sort of yeah that particular case does
it evaluate or not
um
I would argue that the immediate
evaluate does not
disappear I would I would claim that you
know immediate evaluate there's a hint
is a hint
all right so what's your example next to
f
and put the thing inside the immediate
yeah change that to F and put a Lambda
put a function inside you know slots
plus two
slot plus two Ampersand put the
Ampersand inside the immediate evaluate
right the wrapper holds of f
um bracket through
F right yeah three right so
should that
you know sort of evaluates should the
immediate evaluation whatever we call it
trigger there
right and
I'm just saying I think there's an
endless stream of the these cases okay
so let's understand why this doesn't
evaluate
because it's not in the first argument
of map or on the right but but I think
that's not General enough I mean if here
you put this immediate evaluate it
becomes the F pair
yeah it would return hold of immediate
evaluative slot plus two Ampersand of
three
right I mean
well I claim that that immediate
evaluate should evaluate because it is
it was placed by a substitution process
[Music]
um
well
but but right but but at that by that
logic I mean if you did the immediate
evaluate of of that thing of anything
right it'll
uh
I mean
okay the question is what event counts
the substitution
we had a very bright line which was you
know this was going to be a hint to
various functions that you know you
insert things into existing structures
um
which was you know
you know map star replace starts I know
I know I know but I think there's more
to this I mean I think that the
the concept is I mean
it's the same with like supplied we
don't expect supplied around an F to
still function as an F just
out in the wild no right to map or
whatever it's used in
what's your point too
that immediate evaluate of a function is
is not something that should be treated
as equivalent to that function
okay look look semantics possible
semantics
if the immediate evaluate
is the outermost wrapper
of a thing which is inserted
then do evaluation
on the thing
and evaporate
uh the immediate evaluate
I think the question is
what's the definition of inserted I know
it does with it does with insert or does
with construct yes within such in my
opinion
I came many of these functions do the
equivalent of inserting
but they should do nothing unless the
immediate evaluated at the top level and
so this wouldn't work but for example
oops
uh
what did this do
oh just jump somewhere else
okay
that example that you have your cursor
on now
I'd like to point out that I think that
you're intended semantics for immediate
evaluate here would be equivalent to the
current behavior without immediate
evaluate
because you would evaluate the pure
function
and then substitute that pure function
where you see f
yeah I know I know so it's got so it's
going to look like this
so with already has an implicit
immediate evaluate
you know and the width does but but look
look yes it's just gonna do this
okay that's what it's going to come out
with
and that's just going to sit there
unevaluate it
so the immediate evaluate evaporates
uh but in this case yes it does that but
that's uh you know absolutely not what
we want to happen right I mean the the
point is when we used to me the point of
immediate evaluate there is to you know
end up with five
I know but it's not the right way to use
immediate evaluate then how do you use
immediate evaluation
hold on hold on
I don't think you can do it in this case
I don't think it works in this case
because it has to grab something bigger
than itself
so I was comparing with to like the
equals and the whiff is like the rule in
a replace so I know by keeping look I'm
trying to clarify Jeremy's questions
sorry so in the in the replace family
the right hand side is wrapped in
aveniate evaluate quite separately from
that in the map family the the function
is wrapped in immediate evaluate
this would work but this would not work
immediate evaluate can only cause
evaluation so claim
evaluation in its subtree
okay
you're asking it in this case to do more
than just cause evaluation in that
subtree
I don't follow that at all okay so let
me explain again okay so the point is
that in this case
you are substituting the look at this
this is what happens that immediate
evaluate there turns into this here
you see what I'm saying that I'm sorry
that that substitution turns into this
here
because it does evaluation at the moment
when it is substituted here's its rule
I have substituted I will now evaluate
myself that's what it does upon upon
substitution it evaluates itself not
something outside its subjects
because that's what it does right now
without an immediate evaluation I know
it's not useful in this case I'm not
claiming it's useful I'm just saying the
semantics of immediate evaluate is but
that substitution evaluate your subtree
but but but how is that different from
the case where we mapped immediate value
rate of pound plus two across hold of
one comma two right type in hold on hold
on hold on let me look at that case
immediate evaluate
of hash plus two yep ampersand
yes
comma hold one call or two yep
well and then and then
let's no no not a B I mean I guess it
won't make a huge difference but let's
have one and two instead of A and B yeah
yeah
okay but you agree with my last argument
right
all right okay
it's done its substitution no no no this
happened in the wrong order
because the hope
right well how is that different from
where you're right you're right you're
right you're right
yes the problem is
let me try to add an idea here I think
this is about intersecting something in
the middle between matching and
inserting immediate evaluate happens
before insertion
it says that in good delays for for
example we have much insert and then
evaluate we want something that is much
evaluate and insert
right
now match insert evaluate that's the
usual
let's readilate rule would be evaluate
much incept
yes
so what we want now
is match evaluate insert
except that this case is grabbing
something
right so so instead of map do replace at
La at you know at level two right take
that exact same input change map to
replace
and you know make the first uh well I
guess it I guess we'd have to reverse
the arguments
um
no x blank yeah so yeah x blank goes to
immediate evaluate of angst blank plus
two
X plus two
yep
I just for good measure I'll do this
right so immediate evaluate
would give us
um six and seven
because it's a sub tree
that's a fairly clear case the case that
isn't clear is the scrabbery case
that's correct yep
they're different
they're different examples well I I
agree that they're different examples
but I think it's not a
um
but we could do something by saying
immediate evaluate has a sub value
but then it wouldn't work and hold
complete
actually it wouldn't even work in this
case because of the list
no no no immediate evaluate has a sub
value look
you've got this thing it produced
oh I see I see you you're saying the
immediate evaluate has to do its
evaluation it has to do sub-value
evaluation yeah if it were to be a
sub-value would have to do sub-value
evaluation and then that doesn't work
inside holds complete and it
um yeah and it might not work depending
on where the hold is relative to it
okay but the key Point here is we've got
different cases we've got the
substitution the genuine substitution
case
um which by the way also applies to with
is a genuine substitution case
and in the case of West
what if it's not with x equals immediate
evaluate of something of hold of X but
rather with x equals immediate evaluate
of if some condition comma blah blah
blah blah blah X blah blah blah blah
blah where X is buried inside one of the
Clauses of the f
what about it I mean it will do the
immediate evaluation it will at the time
when it does it it will decide which
branch of the F to take
that's if there's even a branch of the F
that it can take right if the condition
doesn't evaluate to a Boolean and there
aren't four arguments
all right so look let's just understand
what else we've got here but but this is
we have not solved this
uh go ahead sorry I I had to step out
for a second so I'm I'm not sure what
conclusion we came to but I I don't we
haven't solved the immediate evaluate
problem there seem to be two different
things we wanted to do but the the
substitution case seems fairly
straightforward the function application
case seems fraught with difficulty and
we don't see how to do it
and why
you know
why is hint to map not a clear
case
I mean that I'm pretty sure that that is
I mean that is sort of what I'm pretty
sure that's what we concluded last time
um okay but then the other case is not a
hint the other case is that you can just
do it
uh no you have to do it inside of a
replace right
um but what's the case without the
replace
look this case is not a hint to map this
case is a does this case work or not
it's hit the whip
uh well I would I would claim that this
case does not work I I don't I just
don't understand what
why why we're thinking this case should
work
because it's the same as the map case
basically correct
um
no I think it's the replace case
I think that's a rule
expressed as a set
inside
yeah it's a rule that changes the head
there is the additional step of
inserting things in the hash
that's done immediately by their by the
replacement so it's very different
I don't understand that comment
let's just look ahead for a second at
what
um right so I mean we talked about
another version that did substitution of
Lambda functions but didn't evaluate
in some meeting previously
foreign
right so I mean other things
that uh
um I mean
things we wanted to
um
oh okay so
um right so maybe uh you need to
evaluate what's only for pattern
matching
uh you know what America's suggestion
okay okay we're not gonna get this
solved today and we've this this these
notes a little bit of a mess
I think
we need someone a type being one of the
at least one of the people to just go
through this and try and enumerate what
the cases are because we've got you know
more stuff here
we've got um
right so I mean the things we want to
discuss are apply withholding I mean if
if if if in the previous discussion
you'd actually allowed me to set the
agenda and instead of reading your
agenda but go on yes well I I had every
I included everything because you
because what could we discussed because
you jumped all over the place
um but
um you know the thing
um was apply withholding
um
which you know I I guess was something
that was sort of uh the uh you know
dealing with uh
what was something you had
um
[Music]
you know something you had suggested
um that's a different thing again
right
yeah there are a lot there are lots of
there are lots of things here let's
let's try to clarify again pull these
things together
and you know and let's pick this up at a
different time because we're not going
to get the solved today
nope
okay I think that's that's all we can
really do here
um but let's try to pick this up again
soon so we can really push forward on
this
we need to get this solved
I think it's going to get squigglier
before it gets on squiggly and I think
it's going to relate to things like the
package format and God knows what else
Wordsworth
okay well let's wrap up here for today
okay
thanks all see you all soon bye